madame monsieur bonsoir
voici les titres que nous allons
développer dans ce journal la coalition
des conservateurs et de l'extrême droite
prête serment en août riches ils se
partagent à égalité les portefeuilles
ministériels le vice-chancelier d'une
femme du parti populiste en ce
moment-même allocution télévisée du
président autrichien à nantes dans un
service de grands prématurés 5
nourrissant auraient été contaminés par
des germes de son décédé l'autre est
dans un état critique
affaire de corruption dans la
gendarmerie nationale à mestre enquête
sur ces pratiques de pots de vin qui
auraient utilisé un officier la
direction a décidé de parler
les premiers départs aux sports d'hiver
pour les vacances de février la neige
semble être au rendez-vous les
professionnels du tourisme affiche un
bel optimisme
à n'en pas douter en retiendra de cette
journée cruciale pour l'autriche et pour
l'europe ces deux images frappantes
celle de l'extrême droite qui prête
serment au palais de la hofburg obtenant
la moitié des ministères de la coalition
avec les conservateurs
puis un peu plus tard cette poignée de
main que tant le président que les
styles à chacun des nouveaux ministres
du parti populiste
une poignée de ma contrainte et forcée
c'est donc fait l'entrée au pouvoir du
parti de jörg haider sous les huées de
la foule massée sur cette même place où
il ya un peu plus d'un demi siècle
adolf hitler étaient accueillis en héros
après l'annexion de l'autriche sur place
nos envoyés spéciaux
patrice romedenne gilles jacquier on lui
demande de respecter les lois de la
république ainsi que les droits et les
devoirs liés à sa fonction
je prête serment et que dieu me garde
répond le nouveau chancelier
cependant ce le président très fine a
sacrifié à la politesse en saluant les
ministres avec un sens des effusions qui
fait songer à la banquise d'ailleurs il
a la chair de poule le président il a
avoué la veille en évoquant le parcours
politique en zigzag de chenu scène que
le protocole lui impose de saluer les
fat félicité quelques minutes plus tard
à la chancellerie atmosphère beaucoup
moins polaire il est vrai qu'ils sont
entre eux au centre le petit chancelier
auquel l'extrême droite fait la courte
échelle à sa droite
la première femme vice chancelier
d'autriche elle a 39 ans et déjà un
surnom cobra royal dans ce gouvernement
elle passe pour être la chef de la bande
haider une bande dont voici le benjamin
31 ans ministre des finances à droite
soudain une question monsieur fussent
elles
êtes vous fier d'être chancelier si on
fait une conférence de presse on vous le
dira il élude tout comme ils évitent de
s'exposer à la vindicte de ceux qui
depuis ce matin conspuent la coalition
sous ses fenêtres
elle est en position de force je m je
l'attends au lit avec ces personnes
la politique de haider s'inspire de la
détestable politique d'hitler
quoi qu'en dise haider à cela haider
réponse ce soir par un communiqué selon
lui les manifestants sont des pros de
l'agitation payé par l'étranger une
chose est sûre la foule enfle ils seront
en fût de rester devant la présidence
elle est passée ce soir par le parlement
a investi la zone piétonne de la
cathédrale et tenté de pénétrer à
l'intérieur du ministère des affaires
sociales désormais détenu par l'extrême
droite
bilan plusieurs personnes interpellées
et une dizaine de policiers blessés
les autrichiens vous diront que dans un
pays comme leur cela n'a rien
d'anecdotique
dès la cérémonie d'investiture et comme
elle l'avait annoncé l'union européenne
a commencé à mettre en place les
sanctions qu'elle avait décidé à une
majorité écrasante en début de semaine
avec pour effet immédiat la suspension
de tous contacts bilatéraux avec le
nouveau gouvernement autrichien pour sa
part l'ambassadeur d'israël a aussitôt
quitté vienne
reste à savoir si l'europe sera opposé
un front uni les premières hésitations
vu le jour quant à l'attitude à adopter
dans l'avenir jérôme benest au moment
même de l'investiture du nouveau
gouvernement autrichien un avion de la
compagnie el al khit viennent avec à son
bord l'ambassadeur d'israël rappelé dans
son pays
l'ambassadeur américain vient lui aussi
de quitter la capitale autrichienne pour
consultations la signature par jörg
haider d'une déclaration sur les valeurs
démocratiques européennes n'a pas suffi
à rassurer les pays de l'union qui pose
dès aujourd'hui un cordon sanitaire
politique au tour de l'autriche et
maison les quatorze ont décidé de
n'accepter aucun contact bilatéral
officielle au niveau politique avec ce
gouvernement de ne pas soutenir les
candidats autrichiens recherchant des
fonctions dans les organisations
internationales de ne recevoir les
ambassadeurs de vienne dans les 14 pays
qu'à un niveau technique
l'ambassadeur d'autriche à paris se
rendra moins souvent au quai d'orsay il
ne participera plus en principe aux
consultations politiques et les
réceptions se feront plus rares
toutes ces sanctions relève des
relations bilatérales et sont à la
discrétion des états en revanche
l'autriche continuera de siéger dans les
institutions de l'europe
le conseil des ministres que fréquente à
wolfgang schüssel le nouveau chancelier
autrichien quand il était ministre des
affaires étrangères la commission
européenne qui surveillera de près la
politique de vienne avec la possibilité
de sanctionner toute entorse à la
démocratie par une suspension du droit
de vote de l'autriche à l'est dans les
capitales des pays candidats à l'entrée
dans l'union européenne
les réactions sont mitigées pour le
ministre tchèque des affaires étrangères
par exemple il n'est pas question de
heurter de front l'autriche
qui pourrait s'opposer à l'élargissement
de l'europe vers son pays ce qui
n'empêche pas la presse
ici comme ailleurs de s'inquiéter du
phénomène haider voyons à présent
comment la jeune génération autrichienne
a vécu cette journée historique a new
consignes et patrick desmulie se sont
rendus encore un titre dans cette région
gouvernée par jörg haider
choses vues et entendues lorsqu'on entre
deux glissades sur le lac gelé de
klagenfurt
on demande aux jeunes ce qui fait le
succès de jorg haider
ils répondent que c'est sa nouveauté
dans un paysage politique autrichien
trop longtemps figé 30 ans de socialisme
il faut du changement mais si haider
incarne le changement son populisme
sulfureux n'est pas du goût de tous loin
s'en faut aux jeunes que nous avons
rencontrés il inspire même une méfiance
certains investisseurs s'avouent il faut
qu'il ait le gouvernement travailler et
qu'ils arrêtent de se mêler des états d
europe
j'espère de toute façon qui n'arrivera
pas au sommet et qu'il ne sera jamais
chanceux
faut-il avoir peur de haider demande ce
journal dans la bibliothèque de la fac
les étudiants répondent non selon eux la
démocratie qui a amené le parti de
haider au gouvernement est suffisamment
solide pour le cadre et je veux observer
son travail le gouvernement de manière
très critique de toute façon à mon avis
il ya suffisamment d'autres chiens qui
sont sur leurs gardes
keep
et même pour cet étudiant socialiste le
parti de jörg haider est inquiétant mais
pas au point d'être exclu du jeu
démocratique et je crois que c'est un
parti qui joue avec les peurs des gens
c'est un parti d'opposition radicale ça
lui a permis de gagner des points
mais pour autant il ne faudrait pas le
comparer à un parti national-socialiste
être renvoyée au passé nazi de leur pays
d'une manière qu'ils jugent caricatural
c'est la première fois que ça arrivait à
certains de ces jeunes c'est sans doute
ce qui les a le plus blessé dans cette
affaire en allemagne le gouvernement se
dit particulièrement inquiet pour
l'avenir de l'europe
les autorités ont multiplié des
déclarations dans ce sens berlin met en
garde par la voix de son chancelier
contre une autorisation de l'allemagne
où tant de réactions qui tranche avec
une certaine attitude de la population
en croire un sondage paru hier il serait
76 % d'allemands être opposé à un gel
des relations avec l'autriche sur place
olivier lerner l'allemagne va suspendre
ses contacts politiques bilatéraux avec
l'autriche
le communiqué de la chancellerie à
berlin est net et précis
mais les allemands appelés à s'exprimer
à travers un sondage ne voit pas cette
mesure d'un bon oeil 76% d'entre eux
sont opposés au gel des relations
diplomatiques une belle unanimité une
belle majorité solidaire du pays voisins
des gaufres à l'autriche et démocratique
je ne vois pas un danger ce qui est
risqué c'est de geler les relations
diplomatiques
et vous qu'est ce que vous en pensez
je partage son avis le peuple à voter
correctement on accepte la démocratie on
doit accepter le gouvernement philémon
plaît pas on peut pas oublier notre
passé politique
il ne faut pas oublier non cette
évolution n'est pas bonne je ne sais pas
si c'est bon si c'est raisonnable que
les états de l'union européenne sans
vraiment contre et c'est bien la
question que se posent les têtes
pensantes en allemagne
je suis aussi opposé à ce genre de
sanctions que nous avons vu ces derniers
jours où des promesses de sanctions est
à des propositions de sanctions
moi je suis contre parce qu'il y à mon
avis un pêle-mêle à l'intérieur l'union
européenne faute historique pour le
ministre des affaires étrangères l'un
des rares hommes politiques à critiquer
ouvertement jörg haider hommes
politiques nuisibles dans la communauté
juive d'allemagne
on estime que la politique de ryder a
été banalisé sous-estimé attention on
joue avec le feu on a connu des
dictateurs qui ont été élus
démocratiquement et il y en a 1
particulièrement qu'a mise en oeuvre la
shoah à berlin sur cette longue ligne
droite qui conduit à la porte de
brandebourg
hitler pouvait parader à loisir et lui
il tenait toute sa légitimité du peuple
allemand
il ya quelques minutes à peine le
président autrichien thomas ce que ce
style pour la première fois s'est
adressé à la nation lors d'une
intervention télévisée que vous avez
suivi patrie soeur rom des news est à
vienne
comment doit-on décoder l'essentiel de
ce discours dans lequel le président
autrichien demande aux pays européens de
donner une chance à l'autriche
mais bon soir béatrice je crois que le
président autrichien veut tout d'abord
protéger son pays
je crois que sur un plan personnel il a
une forme d'angoua si la peur que
l'histoire retienne qu'il n'a pas su
dire non et en fait ils voudraient que
l'histoire retienne qu'il n'a pas pu
dire non et pour témoigner de sa bonne
foi il a donc mis en garde publiquement
la coalition ce soir il lui a dit que si
elle ne respecte pas les valeurs
démocratiques de l'union européenne il y
aurait de graves conséquences en
autriche et dans le monde entier
j'ajoute que le préambule que le
président a fait signer hier à la
coalition au préambule dans lequel il
demande à la condition de respecter les
droits de l'homme préambule dans lequel
la coalition reconnaît la responsabilité
de l'autriche dans les crimes nazis et
bien ce préambule sera envoyée aux chefs
d'états et de gouvernements de tous les
pays qui ont pris des sanctions contre
le clan l'autriche pardon c'est ce que
le président a annoncé il ya quelques
minutes à la télévision
merci patrice romedenne l'actualité en
france avec d'abord à nantes ces morts
suspectes dans une maternité du chu de
la ville dans ce service de grands
prématurés de décès déjà des nourrices
ans dans un état d'extrême fragilité qui
n'ont pas survécu
des germes détecté dans leur
alimentation pourrait être à l'origine
de ces décès jacques devaux gabriel
camilla qui contient les solutés ville
qui est complètement clair alors que
bien sûr le jour
ce qui est strictement normand ce sont
les perfusions qui sont à l'origine du
décès des deux nourrissons nés
prématurés de 25 et 26 semaines sont
décédé brutalement dans la nuit de lundi
à mardi après avoir reçu une solution de
nutrition préparer dans la matinée or
l'analyse a révélé que les perfusions
contenaient des germes
lorsque vous perfusé des microbes ses
enfants ils peuvent pas résister sont
trop fragiles et l'anomalie c'est qu'on
ait fait refuser des microbes
donc parce qu'on a identifié que ça
venait de la nutrition parentérale donc
de la perfusion qui permet de nourrir
ses enfants et on a eu un défaut de
cette nutrition dont on ne connaît pas
on comprend pas le mécanisme on trouve
la présence de ces microbes dans les
perfusions mais aussi dans des acides
aminés entrant dans la composition du
soluté de nutrition mais il est
difficile de connaître l'origine de la
contamination
ce qu'on ne sait pas encore c'est
comment a pu faire la contamination de
ces solutions d'acides aminés des
perfusions si elles se sont faites lors
de leur production industrielle par
exemple ou lors de la préparation de la
perfusion elle-même qui est une
manipulation assez compliqué puisque 7
ou 8 ou plus un grès dian peuvent être
ajoutés dans un flacon de perfusion donc
ce qui implique de nombreuses
manipulations ep risks éventuelle
contamination
bien évidemment une enquête est en cours
mais le service n'a pas été fermée et
les 12 lits de réanimation sont occupés
mais on a su l'itie que toutes les
précautions sont prises pour éviter que
se renouvellent un tel drame après trois
semaines de grève au collège charles
fauqueux de beauvais ce mouvement des
parents d'élèves et des enseignants qui
ensemble contre l'insécurité rallier à
leur cause d'autres écoles de la ville
un effet tache d'huile pour lutter
contre la violence en milieu scolaire
nabila tabourets des machines de tri le
siège est prévu pour durer et rien ne
semble pouvoir ébranler la volonté des
enseignants et des parents d'élèves du
collège fauqueux de beauvais
les professeurs se sont les premiers mis
en grève c'était il ya trois semaines
les parents d'élèves les ont rejoints
lundi dernier et depuis ils occupent
jour et
ils établissements aucun cours n'est
assuré c'était surtout pour soutenir les
professeurs et puis que bon bah on avait
les mêmes buts
parce que bon le collège est en danger
quand même donc il faut essayer de faire
quelque chose maintenant parce que si on
fait pas maintenant on n'arrivera pas
prêt depuis la rentrée les actes de
vandalisme et les agressions contre les
professeurs et les élèves ne cesse de se
répéter leur ras-le-bol était bien
perceptible de ce matin lors d'une
manifestation dont les rues du quartier
saint-jean en signe de solidarité
plusieurs écoles voisines sont restées
fermées pour la journée et les
commerçants au passage du cortège ont
baissé leurs rideaux
on peut pas gérer la violence les
éléments de plus en plus besoin qu'on
les ait coupés qu'on les comprenne on
peut pas le faire avec matiz élèves dans
les classes
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de raquette
aussi parce que les groupes qui sont le
plus supérieur donc par rapport au petit
ils ont tellement parce que leurs tics
dans les salles qui donne
la particularité des parents des
professeurs réclament 11 créations de
postes d'enseignants jusqu'à présent on
leur a promis une infirmière à temps
plein ainsi que deux surveillants et
quatre éducateurs le rectorat assure
qu'il ne peut pas faire mieux aller au
delà
ce serait d'une part pour moi faire
fonctionner la planche à billets ce qui
n'est pas bien entendu en mon pouvoir
et puis ce serait surtout ne pas veiller
suffisamment à l'égalité de traitement
entre les collèges de l'oise et d'une
manière plus générale entre les collèges
de l'académie d'amiens ce soir la grève
a été reconduite jusqu'à ce qu'une
délégation soit reçue au ministère de
l'éducation nationale l'occupation des
locaux pourrait bien se poursuivre
pendant les vacances d'hiver prévue
vendredi prochain à présent cette
affaire de corruption qui éclate au sein
même de la gendarmerie un magistrat
parisien enquête sur ce qui pourrait
bien être un scandale faisant état de
pots de vin touchés par un officier
chargé d hachette d'uniformes accords
qui a pour habitude le secret mais face
à cette histoire qui risque d'entacher
la profession la direction a décidé de
parler parce qu'elle douce est bon bruno
girodon ils sont près de cent mille cent
mille gendarmes qu'il faut équiper et
habiller un marché colossal pour les
fournisseurs vital pour certains d'entre
eux
claude buch et fabricants d'uniformes
l'avait parfaitement compris pendant
plusieurs années son épouse et lui n'ont
pas lésiné sur les moyens pour obtenir
le marché les chemisette bleu ciel
l'afer a été révélée par l'hebdomadaire
le point en décembre dernier on y
découvre un certain lieutenant colonel
ourdi et du bureau des matériels qui a
mené grand train pendant plusieurs
années
repas aux meilleures tables vêtements de
luxe voyages aux frais du couple bûcher
mon mari avait tellement envie de
fournir la gendarmerie il s'est fait
claquer la porte au nez pendant des
années à vous rendez compte un jour là
global la porte s'entrouvre bourdier
c'était c était la bonne aubaine il
fallait absolument s'engouffrer
l'instant ça marche est quand même assez
important
c'est important qui est ce que votre
connaissance d'autres fournisseurs c'est
pareil écoutez franchement oui
sincèrement oui parce que je pense qu'il
ne fonctionnait que comme ça plusieurs
corrupteurs cela signifie t'il plusieurs
corrompue jusqu'à présent le
lieutenant-colonel our d'iéna rien
révéler de telles mais son avocat
rappelle qu'il était loin d'être le seul
à décider quand on parle des marchés qui
ont été négociées c'est quoi c'est
finalement des marchés
qui concerne des matériels de grande
qualité et qui sont négociés non pas par
monsieur ollier par des gens qui ont le
pouvoir de décision
on est à zig et c'est une commission
avec des gens qui on est grave grave
bien supérieure et la direction de la
gendarmerie n'est pas loin de dire la
même chose c'est la première fois
qu'elle communique officiellement sur la
sphère n'auront pas comptés plein fouet
non construite lors on partait chez bill
d'accord pour vous cette affaire se
limite aux errements d'une seule
personne d'un seul gendarme
je me garderai de neupro marché
aujourd'hui
disons simplement que ce n'est pas
l'hypothèse la plus probable c'est à
dire que vous pensez que de la fermer
j'ai retenu qu'il ait agi seul
le lieutenant-colonel ouvrier a été prié
de prendre une retraite anticipée il ya
quatre ans mais la justice aimerait bien
savoir ce qui se passait exactement au
service des plans et moyens elle
s'intéresse déjà à d'autres marchés que
ceux des vêtements alertait la listeria
concernant cette fois-ci l'ensemble des
produits de charcuterie de la société sa
part fabriqué avant le 20 janvier
les produits concernés représentent 50
tonnes ils ont été retirés des étalages
et bien évidemment les consommateurs
sont invités s'ils les ont à ne pas les
consommer quand on reparle de la
cagnotte fiscale de bercy avec ces
nouvelles estimations à la hausse avancé
par nos confrères du monde qui affirme
documents à l'appui que le gouvernement
aurait dans sa cassette 66 milliards de
francs de recettes fiscales
supplémentaires à chiffre immédiatement
démentie par le ministère de l'économie
reste le débat une nouvelle fois ranimer
sur le pas cité des comtes que faire de
cet argent et surtout comment le
distribuer les réactions politiques se
succèdent
chacun son idée jean-paul chapelle dans
les caisses de l'état
beaucoup plus d'argent que prévu mais
combien 13 milliards de francs trouvé en
novembre 24 milliards de francs avoué en
décembre
chaque fois l'opposition soupçonne le
gouvernement de cacher d'autres rentrées
fiscales
aujourd'hui le monde chiffres cette
cagnotte à 66 milliards
le moment est venu puisque cagnotte
il y a de rendre aux français l'argent
de la croissance l'argent nouveau ne
doit pas servir à nourrir des dépenses
nouvelles
alors que nous avons déjà le record
mondial des prélèvements publics
l'argent nouveau doit servir à baisser
les impôts des français
dans un communiqué le ministère des
finances juge totalement fantaisistes le
chiffre de 66 milliards
hier à l'assemblée le premier ministre
avait déjà démenti une première
estimation
il me semble que nous n'en serons pas au
chiffre de 45 milliards qui est une pure
extrapolation et qui de toute façon pour
une partie déjà les 24 a été utilisé en
attendant les socialistes eux mêmes
commencent à s'agacer du manque de
transparence budgétaire faut bien
reconnaître que le parlement est bien
souvent court circuiter au niveau des
informations et particulièrement des
informations financières je pense que
progressivement le parlement doit
retrouver son rôle et doit être informé
en temps réel de l'exécution du budget
de l'état le suspense prendra fin
mercredi prochain quand le ministre de
l'économie christian sautter présentera
les comptes définitifs au parlement plus
la cagnotte sera abondante plus vives
sera le débat pour partager les fruits
de la croissance
cette méga fusion la plus importante
jamais réalisée avec l'union du
britannique vodafone à l'allemand
mannesmann un mariage qui permet la
création du numéro un mondial de la
téléphonie mobile après une bataille de
plusieurs mois yann frontier ce n'est
pas la franche embrassades
mais ne vous fiez pas aux décors ou à la
sobriété de la mise en scène malgré les
apparences ici s'est conclue le plus
grand raid boursier de l'histoire un
raid conclu par un accord à l'amiable
hier soir vodafone le britannique a
absorbé l'allemand mannesmann pour un
montant de 1200 1 milliards de francs
une opération qui créé un géant de
l'économie internationale en valeur
boursière
cette nouvelle entité devient selon les
spécialistes le quatrième groupe mondial
derrière microsoft ou general electric
pour chris ghent le patron de vodafone
cette affaire est bien sûr une réussite
je pense que le public et les
actionnaires allemands ont compris que
notre offre était constructive et
créative
pour nous c'est une victoire en prenant
le contrôle amicale de madness man
vodafone devient le leader incontesté de
la téléphonie mobile
le numéro un mondial avec 42 millions de
clients présents dans 25 pays et pour
s'implanter encore plus sur ce marché en
pleine évolution
il aura notamment pour allier jean marie
messier le pdg du groupe français
vivendi
ensemble ils veulent mais les le mobile
et internet
le grand enjeu des télécommunications de
demain la signature d'une charte
mondiale contre le cancer jacques chirac
à l'issue du congrès a lancé ce défi des
années à venir un plan extrêmement
ambitieux pour une meilleure prise en
charge et une recherche commune
internationale contre ce fléau entouré
de nombreuses personnalités
internationales
le chef de l'état puis écouté par vidéo
ce message d'hillary clinton qui n'avait
pu faire le déplacement
hubert védrine le chef de la diplomatie
française a rencontré au kremlin
aujourd'hui vladimir poutine il fut
question bien sûr de l'otage français
brice le tuyau enlevé en octobre dernier
pas de promesse russe et aucune
assurance quant à une libération
prochaine
le conflit en tchétchénie fait également
à l'ordre du jour sur place alan salvan
ils marchent d'un pas décidé ne type du
pam et semble en même temps un peu
gauche timide c'est le nouveau maître du
kremlin vladimir poutine une énigme dont
on ne connaît que le passé de maître
espion énigme que le ministre français
des affaires étrangères est venu sont
des jauges et 1h15 de conversation et
une impression plutôt positive
les directs les il analyse vite les
choses on sait de quoi on parle on peut
parler utilement
on est d'accord on se comprend on n'est
pas d'accord on s'explique et justement
après les faits réels discours sur la
séculaire amitié franco russe vladimir
poutine n'a pas mâché ses mots en
reprochant à la france d'avoir été la
plus virulente contre l'intervention
russe en tchétchénie créant même dans
l'entretien une certaine tension
il se peut que les russes n'ai pas
compris au nom d'une amitié franco russe
historique que la france soit en pointe
en effet dans cette critique pour dire
qu'il fallait une solution politique est
pas une solution purement militaire
bon mais nous assumons ça que la
tchétchénie reste comme une épine dans
les relations franco russes n'a pas
empêché de ladignac outin de se montrer
attentif et informer sur le sort de
brice fleutiaux otages d'un groupe
tchétchène depuis le 1er octobre
attentif et informer et aussi
apparemment décidé de faire quelque
chose nouvelle flambée de violences au
kosovo sept soldats français ont été
blessés en fin de matinée baisser
légèrement à mitrovica
après une nuit d'affrontements entre les
deux communautés albanaise et serbe
le bilan est lourd sept morts plus de 20
blessés maryse burgot ils sont albanais
et s'ils s'attaquent aux troupes de la
kfor c'est parce que celle-ci des
empêche d'aller en découdre avec les
serbes rassembler de l'autre côté
c'était à mitrovica cet après midi sur
le fameux pont qui sépare la ville en
deux d'un côté les albanais de l'autre
les serbes
la guerre est finie depuis plus de sept
mois mais la violence et la haine entre
les deux communautés n'a jamais cessé
cette nuit encore six albanais ont été
tués plusieurs par balles dans la rue ou
dans leur appartement des crimes qui ont
toutes les allures d'actes de
représailles
lui récemment dans quelques événements
qui peuvent expliquer ce regain de
tension savez qu'il ya toujours plus de
lieux nasser a été pris pour cible par
une roquette de personnes de deux serbes
deux personnes de vue avaient été tués
dans cet attentat c'est vrai ce genre de
choses et frottera à faire remonter les
tensions devant la gravité de la
situation la kfor a évacué aujourd'hui
les 4000 albanais qui vise dans la
partie serbe de mitrovica la ville et ce
soir sous couvre-feu
il ya deux ans le préfet claude erignac
était assassiné en corse ce matin un
office était célébré à paris en présence
de madame erignac et de ses enfants une
famille qui se bat toujours pour
connaître la vérité sur cet assassinat
dans un entretien à nos confrères du
point madame erignac s'est indigné de
voir les nationalistes corses avoir été
reçu par le premier ministre l'aîné
jospin en haute-garonne cinq
spéléologues sont bloqués depuis
mercredi soir dans une grotte des
contreforts pyrénéens
d'importants moyens de secours sont sur
place le groupe aurait été surpris par
cette journée de vendredi celle des
départs en vacances
veuillez m'excuser la neige est au
rendez vous comme ont pu le constater
didier guyot philippe iv neige et soleil
à la clusaz du coup bien avant que le
flot des vacanciers n'arrive quelques
centaines de privilégiés profitent déjà
et plaisirs de la montagne le bonheur
avant les autres personnes du soleil
enneigement pas mal
m le bas des pistes et de mettre à 2500
mètres plus haut débit un taux
d'occupation de 100% du 12 au 26 février
80 à 90 % pour les autres semaines les
neuf mille lits proposés aux touristes
par la station ont été pris d'assaut
on reste toujours dans ces trous
remplissage sont vraiment excellents
c'est difficile de faire mieux c'est 100
% 90 concentre sur deux semaines c'est
très difficile soit plus aux fouilles
donc la tendance est bonne parce que la
neige est excellente il a fait beau et
c'est vrai que ça ça amène la gaieté on
va dire chez tout le monde
club vacances studio où hôtel comme ici
dans ce trois étoiles cela c'est depuis
décembre que les réservations ont été
effectuées
il n'y a pas si longtemps en attendait
le client aujourd'hui il revient sans
complexe
nos prix n'ont pas beaucoup évolué donc
je sais pas s'ils ont le plus d'argent
mais c'est vrai qu'il n'ya pas du tout
de de rossi pas les prix il n'y a pas du
tout de problème avec le tarif de
l'hôtel mais pratiquer le ski ou le surf
à outrance c'est fini ou presque ce que
souhaite désormais la clientèle ce sont
des plus des animations des jeux pour
les enfants et une bouffée de nature les
demandes vers de l'air pur vers vers de
beaux paysages vers des vacances c'est
ça aussi qui fait que la montagne en ce
moment prend des parts de marché gagne
du terrain et tant mieux mais je crois
que c'est ça qui demandait si le ski
certes la montagne l'air pur tout tout
ce qui va autour c'est une demande forte
de la clientèle pas seulement française
ailleurs étrangers a également bien sûr
dans certaines stations la neige se fait
désirer les clients boudent un peu mais
dans l'ensemble en février les pistes
s'annonce embouteillée rugby à la veille
de la première journée du tournoi des
six nations de mac rdif le quinze de
france emmenée par bernard laporte
espère gommer la défaite en finale de la
coupe du monde
portrait de fabien pelous international
depuis 95
il retrouve le poste de ses débuts
internationaux sébastien roux frédéric
de la rue
voici le nouveau géant de l'équipe de
france à mettre 80 18 désormais une
pointure pour le rugby français
au fil des années fabien pelous a pris
de la hauteur chez les bleus un rugbyman
aux 48 sélections au naturel plutôt
discret à 26 ans il est aujourd'hui
capitaine une récompense pour le
distingue jeu mais j'avais d'autres
capitales jamais eu d'ambition
personnelle d'un à ce sport j'ai j'ai
toujours eu des ambitions collectives de
gagner des matches avec avait mais mes
coéquipiers et de me faire
le palmarès je dirais collective fabien
pelous sur un terrain un guerrier ou un
combattant difficile dans ces conditions
de le maîtriser
un capitaine symbole de courage un
modèle de référence pour tous ses
adversaires du tournoi des six nations
c'est un gars vraiment sympa et j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour lui tant pour
l'homme que pour le joueur
son talent est indiscutable vous savez
c'est un gagneur hors pair et en plus
est un très bon meneur d'hommes un bon
capitaine avec le seul faux pas de
fabien pelous dans sa jeune carrière
lors de la dernière coupe du monde le
français piétinent à l'adversaire il
sera sanctionné
un geste qui veut désormais oubliée pas
envie de passer pour un point joueurs
viola d'avoir cette image là parce que
je suis je pas disparaître les joueurs
gagnent donc je pense que je vais enfin
je passe je suis sûre samedi de dorer le
blason de ce côté là et d'être et d'être
exemplaire samedi après-midi face aux
gallois fabien pelous débutera son
capitanat
depuis quinze jours sa vie a été
consacrée aux médias demain un nouveau
défi l'attend il devra désormais
s'exprimer sur le terrain
mauvaise performance de cédric pioline
pour le premier tour de la coupe davis
le français s'est fait battre par le
brésilien fernando homélie génie en cinq
sets 7-5 5-7 4-6 6-1 6-4
à 3 heures 34 minutes de jeu les joueurs
de l'équipe ivoirienne de football ont
été consignées dans un camp militaire
pour leur apprendre le sens civique
c'est du moins la formule qu'utilisait
le porte parole de la junte militaire au
pouvoir pour expliquer ce qui
s'apparente désormais à une affaire
d'état
éric meunier projet rate
après trois jours de détention dans un
centre d'entraînement militaire
les 22 joueurs de la sélection nationale
ivoirienne auront au moins appris une
chose le paka danse les éléphants de
côte d'ivoire éliminée prématurément de
la coupe d'afrique des nations en
presque libre mais il leur reste une
formalité
écoutez la leçon du chef de l'état le
général robert gueï quand on aime son
pays les pieds doivent jouer mais le
coeur aussi bas joué la plupart de ces
joueurs sont des professionnels et
évoluent dans de grands clubs européens
le nouveau pouvoir des militaires n'en a
cure il a promis de remettre de l'ordre
dans la maison ivoirienne
et quel meilleur exemple un premier
avait justement c'est prochainement vous
pas démolir le pays qu'on vous l'avez
fait vous resterez aucun au minimum vous
laisserez point bas le teint de la durée
de votre service militaire il est 20
heures les footballeurs peuvent
maintenant regagner leurs clubs
respectifs certains se précipitent à
l'aéroport pour sauter dans un avion
quelques commentaires à mi chemin entre
crainte et incompréhension des moments
que je pense que plusieurs mois et avait
vu de voir ma famille m là et d'être de
mirande et en france mon dieu mon corps
qui tue mais perd régulièrement quand tu
vois quand même
la france contre la bulgarie qui du
monde
la donne est arrivé second bon on peut
pas imaginer qu'on les amène en commença
à joinville bat religion ville on
l'apprendra marché ou gardez vous en
faites un la question est aujourd'hui de
savoir combien accepteront de revenir
jouer pour leur équipe nationale
après cet épisode rocambolesque il a 100
ans jour pour jour naissait anouilh et
jacques prévert celui qui a donné à la
poésie ce dimension populaire a connu
une patients qui a marqué son oeuvre
claudie lui inspire et barbara et les
feuilles mortes
rien que ça j'avais mené claude barnier
ont retrouvé ce témoin privilégié c'est
aujourd'hui une petite dame qui vit avec
ses souvenirs
en 1938 elle a 16 ans elle rencontre
jacques prévert qui en a 38
le scénariste du jour cela elle est
attirée par cette adolescente épanouie
par sa fraîcheur son naturel sa
simplicité me rendais compte ces petits
eux étaient encore me rendais bien
compte que ça l'intéressait il était
tellement gentil
elle ne sait pas encore qu'elle aime
mais lui déjà ne peut plus se passer
d'elle
s'il ne la voit pas dans ce quartier de
saint-germain-des-prés où ils vivent
tous les deux il lui laisse des petits
mots d'illustrer ça m'ennuie de te
savoir souvent sous la pluie avec des
chaussures qui peuvent prendre l'eau
enfin il se laisse aller à leur passion
réciproque
on était tellement bien ensemble on
s'amusait à table et il est drôle il
était très drôle vous savez quand on
sortait un tableau n'était pas question
du tout de travail né de rien du tout en
plaidant tel était très moqueur et moi
aussi
pendant les six années qu'ils passent
ensemble
il n'écrit que déchets d'heure pour le
drame
quai des brumes les visiteurs du soir
les enfants du paradis
elle sous le nom de claudie carter c'est
du cinéma
un jour pourtant elle rencontre
constants un footballeur professionnel
elle quitte prévert il lui écrit les
feuilles morts 56 ans plus tard constant
est toujours à ses côtés
mais ils écoutent encore claude icart
tard raconté la grande passion de
prévert une fois tu étais artistes près
de moi et surtout un respect du feu et
tu as dit je t'aime autant que le feu
fin de ce journal je m'en rappelle le
principal titre la coalition des
conservateurs et de l'extrême droite qui
prête serment en autriche
ils se partagent à égalité les
portefeuilles ministériels le vice
chancelier est une femme du parti
populiste le président autrichien vient
de s'exprimer dans une allocution
télévisée dans un instant la météo
isabelle martinez puis le poids route de
valérie maurice 20h55 migraient minus ac
le dernier journal florence duprat de
master dans thé ou café catherine ceylac
reçoit marielle nordmann qui et harpiste
quant à moi j'aurais plaisir de vous
retrouver de man dès 13 heures je vous
remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2